foreign
riot police fire and tear gas and
protesters hurling rocks and fireworks
back at them
this was the same square where 17 year
old Niel died on Tuesday Morning shot by
the police these clashes were loaded
with Fury and mistrust
this man asking people to film The Place
everywhere all the time Nile's killing
was filmed by a passerby
and at the heart of this protest Nile's
mother here holding the flare the focal
point of support
she led a March through nantair that
attracted thousands from across this
community many knew her son Bruno's
lived in nante his whole life his
children the same age as nail and the
passengers who were with him in the car
they know his friend the one who got
away is hiding because if he gets caught
by the police we'll never see him again
and he's the main Witness
the prosecutor has now charged the
police officer involved in the shooting
with voluntary homicide but that hasn't
quelled the tension
well the death of Niall was the Catalyst
for this protest but there is a lot more
behind us this is a community that feels
forgotten disenfranchised and also look
around you you can't see a single
uniformed police officer here these
people considered the police to be the
enemy
the government's reaction is to summon a
lot more police to protect the streets
of France if people
disorder professionals must go home I've
decided there'll be 40 000 police and
gender mobilized this evening and
tonight including 5 000 in Paris and
significant Technical and technological
means will be provided to fight against
these riots to carry out arrests and to
restore the Republican order that the
French legitimately expect
this is what we saw last night in
non-term fires burning wildly destroying
property in the darkness in parts of
France there is now a sense of
lawlessness and Anarchy